[Music]
it appears absent the x-men are arriving
with what are you doing my job
you're the one who said I was ready and
I frankly disagree with you but here we
are trying to overcome our differences
like Beyonce says please please stop
cheating on me hey this is the fifth
incident this kid needs to be in a nice
box not here Russell belongs in our care
not in prison I assure you we have
everything under control not getting a
real under control vibe here Marty it is
Glenn isn't it Daniel I'll ask the
questions let me talk to the kid
you stay here with your weird secret sex
lips adorable I don't know why I packed
the hollow points oh did you just say
hollow points yeah probably shoulda
brought a SuperSoaker hi there
stay back or Justin Bieber dies huh
that's the beaver he called you Justin
Bieber wait okay let's let's not do
whatever that is okay let's just talk
great sums Russell right fire fist fire
fist ooh that's a great name where does
it burn just the fist or all the way up
to the elbow come quietly or dead it
will be trouble you stole that from
Robocop Robocop just stand down you're
embarrassing me look fire pit yeah
[Music]
we're gettin close you all know the
drill
intercept the convoy watch out for cable
edit there's this kid he's in trouble
Rupert I pump the hate breaks Thanos
anyone cable get tool I can't do this
alone made backup we're gonna form a
super duper group it's time to get back
on LinkedIn meets bed and look
my name is chatter stark Domino I'm
lucky luck isn't a superpower it's
certainly not very cinematic yes it is
let's meet in the middle and say no it
is alright it's show time don't call it
a comeback
you're no hero you're just a clown
dressed up is it going so dark you sure
you're not from the DC University
[Music]
bring it on one-eyed Willy
oh yeah your bullets they're really fast
and last but not least Peter
any powered want to tell us about you I
don't have one I just saw the ad you're
in
[Music]